[Música]
não sei se vocês já ouviram falar que no
dia que o presidente eo presidente lula
ea ser preso com um carro que tinha
quatro cubanos sofreu um acidente numa
estrada no sul do país
todos eles morreram em um acidente feio
ea polícia vai investigar e descobriu
que eles tinham armas e bombas eles
estavam indo pro rio grande do sul onde
fica o tribunal regional federal que
julgou os recursos do luva
não sei se vocês souberam que semana
passada um caminhoneiro cometeu suicídio
depois que ele recebeu uma notificação
do depois que recebeu uma notificação do
governo que ele ia ser multado em 400
mil reais porque ele bloqueou uma
estrada durante a greve de caminhoneiros
não sei se vocês ouviram essas notícias
não sei se vocês compartilharam eu
espero muito que não porque tudo que eu
falei até agora é mentira é tudo fique
news ea gente precisa falar sobre o
cheque mills porque é um assunto
importante a gente tem ano de eleição
não é só bobagem fec news não é só outro
dia me mandaram cláudio você da globo eu
trabalho no g1 site de notícias quando
você da globo é verdade que o pablo
evitar vai ter um programa infantil na
globo pra pregar a ideologia de gênero
não falei não longe a gente quer o que
não ocorreu
o propósito de alguém inventar uma
mentira df tem tiras bem finas que a
gente sabe exatamente propósito que é
interferir com as eleições a gente viu o
tanto de aliás o termo fake nilzo
começou a ficar em voga bastante no ano
passado no final de 2016 ano passado
quando teve eleição donald trump e não
sei se a gente gravava que que foi
responsável mas as pessoas tentaram
interferir então fique news é perigoso
falar sobre feminismo que não se pode
matar gente tem uma mulher que chamava
fabiane maria de jesus ela tinha 33 anos
em 2014 e ela foi linchada pelos
vizinhos dela depois que um portal de
notícias
guarujá divulgou que tinha uma mulher
fazendo trabalho de magia negra e
seqüestrando crianças para os rituais e
o portal divulgou uma notícia um retrato
falado e aí a galera ele achou que era
parecido com ela pegar mulher na rua
espancaram até a morte
filmaram por causa de uma notícia falsa
então a gente precisa falar sobre fé
cnews filhos não é novo sempre existiu
esse é um jornal de pênalti aos 43
dizendo que os nazistas tinham
dinossauro não é um jornal fake que
alguém pela internet é um fenômeno
também mas enfim definiu sempre existiu
não sei se vocês lembram na copa de 98
depois que o brasil perdeu daquele jeito
começou a rolar os emails é assinado por
um cara chama gamper para um nome alemão
que trazia toda a verdade sobre a final
da copa que o brasil tinha vendido a
copa da frança e euna e que tinha pago
87 e todo mundo receber e mail receber
esse meio eu falei será que é verdade
enfim acho que não é mas a questão aqui
foi que eu sempre existiu
a diferença hoje é que não é um jornal
publicado
não é uma corrente de e mails
hoje eu fique news ela se propaga assim
a velocidade da luz é uma página com
milhares de seguidores no facebook que
ela está dando bastante dor de cabeça
por mark zuckerberg isso uma vaga com
milhares de seguidores no facebook vai
lá e coloca a notícia falsa as pessoas
vão caramba e é isso que compartilha com
os amigos que compartilham com os amigos
e de repente vai ou então o que eu acho
que é pior do que isso é uma coisa que
vem muito perigosa que vem disfarçada de
um sol em formato de coração com uma
cara bondosa desejando uma boa quarta
feira cheia de amor pra todos vocês e
que pode ser uma arma de guerra que
chama grupo d o desafio da sua família
quando a marielly foi assassinada a
vereadora do rio de janeiro começaram a
circular na internet
é uma notícia falsa sobre ela tinha
gentinha a notícia que falava que ela
tinha sido casada com
marcinho vp um traficante que ela tinha
engravidado 16 anos
como se isso fosse aí tudo bem foi isso
então pode ser fuzilado no meio da rua
mas enfim começar a compartilhar e teve
um grupo da usp que fez um estudo de um
grupo da usp fez um estudo para saber
tentar rastrear de onde veio isso eles
fizeram questionar online como as 2500
pessoas boa parte delas tinha recebido
essa informação falsa sobre a marielly
em metade das pessoas que receberam
receberam do grupo d o desafio da
família porque é um grupo que pede você
confia
ninguém está ninguém fiscaliza porque
grupo tap é fechado agora porque as
pessoas esperam esse tipo de coisa
juntos que vem fraquinhos quem faz
pequenos que inventa pequeninos
a gente divide é slide que também o é só
pra gente tem uma idéia mais ou menos
têm pequenos que vem de site humorístico
que é ali o sensacionalista esse site
que inventam manchetes só que às vezes a
gente vive uma realidade tomizawa que as
pessoas acreditam em uma chave de joelho
ea pessoa só queremos se viu isso e aí
compartilha que não era pra ser um civil
foi criado tem feito news que manipula
um contexto pega informação genuína muda
o título pra ficar mais sensacionalista
para as pessoas ficarem em fake news que
pega um conteúdo 11 uma coisa em um site
conhecido e clona e pega ali por exemplo
o rádio de um logotipo do g1
para inventar uma notícia para a
sucessão a gente é verdade saiu hoje um
outro dia tinha uma dessa que era uns
turistas no rio de janeiro
saltaram de parapente e aí estamos lá
chorando tal e aí de repente chegou dois
mano no parapente com a área e perdeu
playboy e roubar os turistas do
parapente tipo gente com a chance de
acontecer
quer dizer foi lá no rio de janeiro 2016
assim não vamos lá isso compartilhar
gente osos ao g1 que é isso
uma leitura minimamente atenta civic
odyssey completamente errada mas as
pessoas compartilham
háháhá a notícia que é verdadeira
só que era tirada de contexto que é
sempre perigoso você tiver com esse
contexto
vou usar de novo exemplo da marielly
quando ela morreu começaram a falar há
no mesmo dia às quais só chorando com a
morte dela
no mesmo dia uma médica foi assassinada
durante um assalto
só que ela era médica rica branca e aí
ninguém fala nada que há pelo menos mil
contrário mas e de fato e no mesmo
aquela mesmo no mesmo dia de março
morreu uma médica no galera gisele ela
foi assassinada na linha amarela no rio
de janeiro na barra da tijuca
só que foi dois anos atrás foi no mesmo
dia de março dois anos antes e sim a
imprensa falou e fez barulho e hoje é um
deu ea globo deu ea folha de são paulo
deu então as pessoas tiram de contexto
você vai falar caramba é verdade olha
que horror e tem o conteúdo fabricado
que é 100% inventado a um site feito
para propagar feminino porque as pessoas
clicam as pessoas dão audiência o site
ganha com o anúncio e pronto para ganhar
dinheiro espalhando mentiras por aí
agora porque as pessoas espalhou fake
news
olha só que é uma matéria do acidi de
2016 que as notícias da lava jato
naquele ano foram mais compartilhadas do
que às notícias fake do lava jato foi
mais compartilhados que as notícias
verdadeiras tem um estudo do emapte que
eles divulgaram este ano em abril
eles analisaram 3 milhões de notícias
compartilhadas no twitter desde 2006 até
o ano passado notícias compartilhadas
por quatro milhões e meio de pessoas ea
conclusão deles é que uma notícia falsa
tem 70% mais chances de ser
compartilhado por alguém com uma notícia
verdadeira essa notícia foi de política
e rothen tipo três vezes mais chance no
ano de eleição isso é perigosíssimo
mas as duas compartilham tudo notícia de
saúde de ciência tem pra caramba notícia
de desastres naturais
fotos tiradas de contexto agora por que
será que as pessoas porque será que as
pessoas é compartilham fake news desse
jeito
os estudiosos têm algumas
às vezes assim né primeiro que fique
news elas são feitas para serem
compartilhadas
então elas sempre são surpreendentes e
inusitadas
elas têm os títulos muito chamativos
outros última notícia no g1 que era
sobre a vacinação da gripe que era
alguma coisa tipo
o governo ainda precisa vacinar 24% da
população para chegar até a meta
vi que alguém compartilhou isso devia
falar a gente vamos vacinar precisa não
é uma coisa séria vacina da gripe
só que tinha uma fé que deus quer assim
médico do sus conta toda a verdade sobre
a vacinação da gripe dois pontos
há pessoas morrendo exclamação aí sim o
negócio de se classificar uma
descontraída com índices botar no grupo
da família
então é uma coisa sedutora que as
pessoas sentem necessidade de
compartilhar mas a gente faz o que
sempre chora e fala eu acabo o mundo
esquece ninguém vai saber o que é
verdade acho que não espero que não
porque as pessoas querem se informar
então é papel da imprensa fazer bom
jornalismo se fazer um ser transparente
fazer ter credibilidade porque as
pessoas querem se informar
a gente é esse próximo slide aqui é o
número de buscas no google sobre o termo
fake news
olha da eleição do trump para lá todo
mundo começou a falar que é isso que
fique news porque depois da eleição do
trump que a gente pode falar mal dele
que daqui a pouco ele vai ganhar um
nobel da paz como acordo com o quintal
mas enfim é as assinaturas digitais do
new york times elas cresceram assim ó
monte até que tem um slide sobre isso
cresceram pra caramba só que é isso que
é o tráfico não é de assinaturas - que
serão muito do do oeste com post do new
york times porque as pessoas querem se
informar as pessoas não querem ser
enganadas
algumas só querem dependendo as pessoas
querem acreditar no que elas querem mas
eu quero crer que a maioria das vezes
não quer ser enganado
então a gente precisa ter um jornalismo
de credibilidade a gente precisa fazer
correto e não só isso porque ultimamente
não basta a gente fazer o nosso papel de
emprego
o dia atrás de e atrás das notícias e
apurar e etc
a gente está tendo que ir atrás do que é
publicado falso pra contar se é verdade
ou não
a gente fez uma auditoria no g1
recentemente faz a gente já fez um ano
já que se chama é ou não é que a gente
tem uma equipe para ir atrás de boato
para saber se é verdade ou não e assim
tem um monte assim acho que em um ano a
gente tem selar os 200 boatos
acho que 2% deve ser verdade tem das
coisas mais absurdas que falar na
possível que as duas na note se que a
pessoa compartilha isso e tem coisa que
realmente hoje a cidade tem coisa que é
igual mostrei uma notícia tirada de
contexto essa história dos cubanos que
eu contei no começo ela aconteceu os
caras tinham a teve um acidente com
quatro cubanos mas coitados estão indo
pro uruguai tentar morar lá tentar um
refúgio lá então a gente ainda tem esse
problema de temos que fazer bom
jornalismo
temos que informar que nos fazer o
público confiar e temos que ir atrás dos
boatos
temos que checar a gente usa um monte de
ferramenta de twitter de saber que é
busca no google que está sendo buscado
que tem engajamento no facebook que as
pessoas estão compartilhando nos grupos
que é o mais difícil de saber então as
pessoas às vezes encaminham projeção a
gente tem um canal ali para as pessoas
encaminharem pra gente ver o tanto que a
gente precisa desmentir o tempo todo
a gente está num ano perigoso a gente tá
no ano de eleição que ninguém sabe muito
que vai vir na seleção
ottawa mostrando os meus dois discutam
meio fora de hora isso aqui número de
visitas do g1 só cresce a gente tem
greve dos caminhoneiros
as pessoas entram no chão pra saber pela
querem se formavam quer ser enganada mas
não querem começa a sair um monte de
outdoor desaprovamos invadir o exército
chegando em brasília de 77 será que é
verdade
as pessoas querem saber mas isso não
pode ser responsabilidade só do da
imprensa dos órgãos de imprensa do site
de notícias da tv porque a cada
desmentido que a gente dá a notícia
feito original ela já foi vista por uma
multidão
não que no final nem vai ver o
desmentido que a gente fez
então a gente tem que a combater fique
news é responsabilidade de todo mundo
de quinta assistindo de quinta sentado
aqui responsáveis da sociedade
a gente tem que ninguém está imune vai
chegar uma fraqueza é você e você vai
identificar ou não você tem que
perguntar de onde veio isso mas é
verdade mesmo ritmo que é absurdo mas
que ninguém está dando isso que site é
esse que está dando a gente que tem uma
foto circulando vai atrás vai no google
vai na ferramenta do google coloca lá
será que é verdade é pra você colocar
ele acha que tem uma foto igual a você
descobre que essa foto de fato acontecer
mas em 2015 que então não é verdade e da
próxima vez que a sua tia de mandar uma
fake news no seu grupo da família
você não tem que virar os olhos a nossa
ignorar que a mulher eles vão começar a
discutir com ela a gente vai não
você tem que ir lá e falar olha só tem
certeza que a verdade
de onde veio qualquer fonte quem está
falando isso não tem ninguém dando a
mais é porque a imprensa esconde esconde
empresa tem concorrentes eu não dou uma
notícia importante o meu concorrente vai
dar vai ter clima para ele a gente a
gente precisa informar nosso dever
informar o público se você não falar
alguém vai falar então eu acho que é
dever de todo mundo porque como falei a
gente tá no ano de eleição ea gente
corre risco de verdade de ser vítima de
phishing news
obrigada
[Aplausos]